just senior Avery big day school right
from every district I got my I got my
lunchbox I've got my passport I got mine
on my phone I got my glasses and your
hoodie decay and farmers I'm a pharmacy
student today
but I can make a lot of friends I hope
that everyone will like me in class a
lunchbox I do not find a pencil
that's my sister I'm so embarrassed
she's 225 senior really run into God
swell ah this way I think I've been
galloping
we're in class here it's my first day
I missed it again
he's even a sensation
I get extra market
yeah ei sauce are twisted yeah ha so
actually captures my professor calls and
after open and tie this the implication
of regards I'm sure not the free
radicals cost the anomalies are
measuring the chopped glasses over but
apparently five minute great is this
oncology hi
they're punic how was your your lesson
will current book
oh don't that stuff up my lunch boxes my
purse is in there good and necessary
question probably because nobody asks
questions right
cool I'm not here okay we're just
leaving class right now I got my
lunchbox
the my lunchbox my pharmacy hoodie on
feel like a real student set I'm gonna
thank anybody was talking about the
glass cool honestly no sociology we know
what's going on either makes me feel a
little better in not too much where we
go no we're going to the library well
this is my quad cuz my excited feet
singing dancing laughing
who always get along
when you're with that Yoji
like to sing a song
are always there for you friends will
always care
why
Lane side do you
so to get a library yeah I can lie let's
do power walk class singing dancing
laughing playing friends who always get
along when you're with them you'll be
happy friends who like to sing a song
are always there for you
we'll always scared
you know they'll be there singing
dancing laughing playing that's where
happiness is found friends will help you
when you're lonely they will always be
around friends who love you friends who
stay tuned vice where happiness is found